all right good morning everyone so we
are gonna be running this with live
captioning today so you can see it
running there at the bottom of the
screen if it glitches out I apologize if
it works successfully Thank You Google
so so we're gonna be talking today I'm
calling this design science here's my
contact info for those of you who are
interested I'll flash it up again at the
very end you couldn't feel free to tweet
nice things about me at any moment all
right so we're gonna start off let's
talk about science and set the
foundation here for what we're gonna be
talking about today just to go back as
mentioned I'm an applied psychologist
and in my training there is a model
called the scientist practitioner it's
called the Balder model of applied
psychology and basically it says that
when you are working as a psychologist
there's a variety of methods and
approaches that are possible and you
should experiment and test and evaluate
those different approaches to find the
one that works most effectively for the
problem in the situation that you are
trying to address in essence every
psychological treatment or interaction
counseling whatever it happens to be is
an exercise in tailoring the methodology
to the problem and that sounds a lot
like design and so we're gonna take a
look at what scientific methods are and
what design methods are and how they are
ultimately very much the same thing and
how we can leverage a scientific
approach to a systematic approach in
design
I am click alright so the scientific
method how many of you are scientists
you have backgrounds in in physical
sciences research sciences okay great so
for those of you who are scientists do
you recognize this right this is
essentially the scientific method make
an observation form a theory and some
hypotheses run an experiment gather data
see if things match up modify the theory
then repeat right you just keep doing it
it's a basically a lather rinse and
repeat type thing now UX design has some
method right you've all seen the
diagrams double diamonds and all sorts
of loopy things and journeys maps and
stuff like that but essentially it
starts is the same thing make an
observation generate an idea test a
potential solution gather data evaluate
and modify the design in fact if you do
a search on google for things like
design process or UX process you get
lots of these little skittle colored and
flavored type diagrams that all have
nice circles and loops and arrows in
them right so we already see that there
are clear overlaps between this now
historically we look at scientific
method as being very rigorous its
structured and it's methodical and one
of the hallmarks of a scientific
approach is that it's reproducible that
we can apply those methods and we can
use them repeatedly and we can do so
reliably that often is also a goal for
us in design right so hailey was just up
here talking about a design language
system which is a very systematic
reproducible rigorous and appliable
methodology now when we think about
science we typically think of things
like this right big complex formulas so
we're gonna write our own formulas as we
talk about design today essentially when
we talk about it from a design
perspective we still boil down to the
idea that I have hypotheses and I make
some conjectures I think this is what's
going on and I think that in certain
situations this is what's going to
happen so the key phrase for us here is
going to be a conjecture now a
conjecture is
essentially a guess or a supposition
right it's what I think is going to
happen and we've got lots of words for
this I believe I think I suspect but
essentially what we're doing is we're
making a prediction and then we want to
go out and see if that prediction
actually happens so here's an example I
like to often talk about the probability
of interaction so if you're designing a
product the probability that someone is
going to interact with it might be
described by a formula the value of the
outcome divided by the work of the
effort to achieve that outcome times my
confidence in my prediction that this
interaction is going to do what I want
it to do in other words if I have to
work really hard for something of low
value and I don't think it's gonna
happen anyway I'm not gonna do it right
so we have three variables and a simple
formula now we can put numbers in for
value and work and confidence and we can
come up with a calculation here but the
real question is what's work what did
this number come from and what does it
mean
or what's value or in this particular
case what do we mean by moderate value
0.55 sounds great moderate right that
was a conjecture it's a total guess I
actually have to do an experiment to
figure out how do i define work how do i
define value and how do i measure those
so we have a model and we make
conjectures we make some assumptions
about them so let's do another one here
just for fun let's say that I'm working
on a touch interface and I have a theory
about how accurately people can drag an
item from one part of the screen to a
target on another part of the screen so
now that involves tap hold grab drag
release drop all of those actions we do
it all the time drag and drop we don't
even think about it
right but what are the variables
involved in how accurate that
drag-and-drop action is so I propose
maybe it's the target size in the visual
contrast of the interface the size of
the contact area my fat finger right how
hard I am pressing against the screen
the distance I have to drag the speed at
which I drag and then some yet to be
defined variable on my manual dexterity
skill right maybe I'm a klutz
maybe I'm highly dexterous so I don't
forget there very easily so I know what
I think the variables are I go and I do
some research what do we already know
about this type of thing so we find Fitz
law or in this case Myers law which is
the adaptation of Fitz law for 2d
environments how many of you have heard
of Fitz law yeah so Fitz law is actually
for three-dimensional environments Myers
law is an adaptation of Fitz law for two
dimensional environments so it's more
appropriate for our drag-and-drop
situation I can go to physics and I can
say ok so I know the relationship
between acceleration and time and
distance so I've got some starting
formulas and I start to plug things in
and I come up with this right every
designer does this in your spare time so
the accuracy happens to be some
constants alpha and beta and then a big
function of all of these other variables
and I'm like great I've got something
now that I can use to predict how
accurately people will drag and drop
targets on a touchscreen
the problem is we have a bunch of
unknown values right and I'm making
conjectures I'm making guesses
assumptions suppositions hypotheses I'm
just guessing right I think these are
the variables and I think they have some
values but how do I figure out whether
or not this actually works so we take
our formula we choose one variable let's
just say force I actually have equipment
in a lab that we could touch and figure
out how much force pressure of force
people are using to touch a surface that
actually is fairly easy to quantify so
I'll start with one that's easy to do so
I choose that one variable and then I
run an experiment and I see how hard are
people pressing on the screen I collect
some data I figure out what the numbers
are what's a normal range how does it
vary based on tap and hold versus tap
and drag because if you press too hard
there's too much friction and your
finger doesn't slide so you have to get
that happy little medium right where
your finger slides across the screen but
you don't actually drop the thing along
the way so I got to figure out what that
value is and then I just keep doing this
process one variable at a time so you
just choose one run an experiment figure
out what it is and how to measure it
plug in the number and then move to the
next variable and after half a dozen
experiments I can fill in my equation
and now I have something reproducible
and testable but it all started with a
bunch of hypotheses it all started with
a bunch of assumptions right the problem
with the assumptions is that conjectures
have a tendency to become assumed truth
if we don't test them if we just put in
a placeholder value and then we don't
come back and evaluate that placeholder
value eventually everyone on the team
begins to think that that value is in
fact the real thing and they don't
question it and they don't test it they
don't evaluate it they don't vary it
they're just of course it's in the
formula it's supposed to be there it's
supposed to be 0.55
right
but you need to ask is this the case
right is this the right variable is this
the right measure is this the right
value so question everything always what
scientists do and it's what designers
should be doing as well so now we've got
an overlap right there are things that
both scientists and designers are doing
divergent thinking abductive reasoning
rigorous reproducible methods plausible
rival hypotheses which basically means
how many ways can I explain something
and then which of those possible
explanations seems to be the best fit
running experiments we run tests and and
stuff all the time on products and then
a systematic analysis we gather data and
we look which product variation is
performing the best so I like to call
myself a designer scientist because I
bring my research science background to
design methodology and I try to have a
very rigorous reproducible and
systematic approach to thinking about
product design all of those decisions
but we can use the exact same
methodology to take an existing product
and try to understand why it may not be
performing as well as it could so I can
use the method to make better design
decisions or I can use the method to
draw insights from an existing product
and we'll see at the end we'll do a
quick example of how that might happen
this is our Buckminster Fuller how many
of you know who Fuller is yeah for those
of you in chemistry you probably know
fullerene for those of you in
architecture you know about the dome
right the fuller dome those big classes
as he looks up into the sky longingly
right in front of his dome now in 1957
he said he named design science for the
first time so I can't take credit for
the title of the talk design science
actually as much older than I am but he
defined it as a systematic form of
designing and for the next 10 years or
so there was a lot of discussion about
science and design in the science of
design and the scientific study of
design and in fact they went and got
themselves stuck for about 20 years
arguing is design science a scientific
method of design or a scientific study
of design and they sort of polarized
themselves and just talked about it in
academic circles and it didn't really go
anywhere until we got to the 1990s when
some theoretical people said oh let's
really dig into this and apply lots of
big vocabulary and so they really
started to think theoretically about
design science now for those of you who
remember 1990s also happens to be when
the internet became a public thing so at
the same time we had a whole bunch of
people that were thinking deep about
what design science is theoretically a
whole new digital experience was
emerging in the world and this idea that
there were distributed digital
information systems for which we needed
to design a way to interact started to
come together with the idea of design
science and by the time we get into the
2000s now and even though the the
the.com bubble burst in 2000 we still
have the Internet still a big thing and
they really started to think much more
critically about design and information
systems and design science really
started to stabilize at that point back
in 2004 Hefner March Park and RAM
published a study in which they
identified a set of designing for
information system methods those blue
things that should look familiar that
should look a lot like a basic
scientific method it should look a lot
like UX processes right but it's a
backbone for a modern approach to design
science so today when we talk about
design science as a phrase it actually
has just come to mean both things
it is a scientific practice of design
and a scientific study of design so
design science it's a flexible term
all right so we're gonna take a look at
design and science but much more
specifically we're going to focus on
psychology as our branch of science here
even though I started with a whole bunch
of physics I'm a psychologist so that's
what we're going to use those are
framing now there are lots of relevant
fields to psychology that we could draw
from here there's a handful of these
that we're actually going to use in this
particular model so here's the caveat
for the day there is a whole lot more to
psychology than the 30 minutes we are
going to be talking about it right here
um this is like the intro to the intro
of an intro book to psychology so this
is not complete and also just to give
you a warning I violate one of my
principles in this deck and that is
there's way too many words on these
slides I'm not going to read them I'm
not going to talk about all of them but
there are links here there are short
links here I want you to have the deck
and I want you to be able to go back and
read it afterwards because there's a lot
more stuff than we're gonna be able to
talk about so I put it here as a future
archive for you
all right so we're gonna start with a
model and I like drawing spacial
versions of models we're gonna start at
the outside and we're going to work our
way in and you're gonna find that we're
going to start by understanding context
we're gonna look at the situation in
which people are located and then as we
narrow in we're going to eventually
focus more on individual psychology and
what's happening in that own person's
experience and in their cognition and in
their thinking so on the outside we just
need to understand the basic context
right who is it where are they what are
they doing what are they using there's a
whole bunch of core questions that we
can be asking but we also have to
understand that in context what are
people bringing with them what's their
prior experience is this a brand new
thing have they used it before have they
used something similar and what
expectations do they have of this
experience what do they think is gonna
happen and what do they think they're
going to have to do so experience and
expectations and then we need to
understand their goals what are they
trying to achieve
what's the desired outcome or what need
is trying to be met and when we take a
look at people's goals we can come up
with two broad buckets for those I call
them productivity and creativity I go
back and forth on these terms quite
often because you could also think of
them as being open ended and closed
ended tasks do I have a specific goal I
am trying to achieve or am I just
playing so those really are the things
am I trying to get something done or am
I just surfing so we'll use those two
general buckets now that sets us up for
context on the outside right now we
understand a little bit about the
situation and the basics of the person
and what they're trying to achieve now
we can focus on the individual
psychology what's happening in that
person's head so we'll talk about just
five areas we'll go in more detail in
these in a moment we start with
sensation and perception how are they
perceiving the product what are they
aware of
moving into motivation what is driving
them right like what is what is causing
them to interact or to try to do
something cognition or thinking and once
again we're going to go more in depth in
each of these what's their emotional
experience what's the social context
increasingly we have to consider what is
going on socially not just within the
individual and then of course behavior
what are they doing right what are they
actually how are they behaving or
interacting with the product
all right so now we have all of the
aspects of our model here I'm just gonna
quickly go in into some more detail but
we're gonna be focusing on this from an
interaction standpoint ultimately what
we're designing for is to get people to
use something to use it effectively
provide value have positive experiences
but what we are looking for what
manifests is an interaction it's what
they actually do so this is one of those
sections where there's a lot more words
I'm going to say less and we're going to
go through it relatively quickly but
more of the detail is here so from the
outside context experience and
expectations what do we mean once again
the person the situation what are the
tools that they're using what experience
have they brought with them and what do
they expect to do or have happen and
there's a whole bunch of questions that
we can ask when we're trying to
understand what is the context and so
each of those little terms is sort of a
cue do I know this can I ask about this
can I learn about this
the goals what are the objectives what
are they trying to achieve but very
importantly we also have to understand
what's the value of the outcome and how
urgent is that need not just what
they're trying to achieve but how
important is it to them and is there a
time pressure is there urgency I need it
now
versus some time is okay or it's not
really that important it's a
nice-to-have or it's absolutely critical
we also we're talking about productivity
versus creativity am i playing a game am
i trying to pay bills online am i
writing a document for work what is the
actual thing I am trying to do now I'll
step aside for a moment and talk about
value and urgency here because people
often conflate these they think that if
something is high value it is also
likely to be urgent and that's not
always the case
now I'm unfamiliar with Canadian tax law
but in the United States the income
taxes are due on April 15th now on
January 1st it is important for you to
be preparing to do your taxes for the
previous calendar year but is it urgent
no I still have three and a half months
right it's January 1st I got plenty of
time now on April 14th it is important
for me to be doing my taxes but now the
urgency has changed right is it urgent
oh yeah these have to be postmarked by
midnight on the 15th so it's important
for the entire time but it's not urgent
in January it is extremely urgent on
April 14th so don't make the the
confusing connection that just because
it's important means it's urgent or just
because it's urgent
doesn't mean it's important how many of
you play games on your phones
yeah the rest of your hands you're just
not showing up so there are games that
you have probably become hooked on right
and you really really want to play and
you really really want to get to that
next level and it is really important
for you to be doing that but is it truly
urgent for you to be playing the game
right now at work right probably not but
you might feel that it is urgent right
earlier I really have to do this
okay perception sensation and perception
here now moving into the individual
psychology bits there's a whole lot that
we could be talking about here most
often however when we're talking about
UX design there are certain things that
we focus on because only three of our
senses are the ones that we typically
are using what are people able to see
what are people able to hear and what
are people able to feel so happy and
vibration feedback for example is
something that we we deal with we don't
have a smell of vision and and things
like that yet but who knows what will
happen maybe someday we'll have scent
designers or we will have taste design
we already do have taste designers
they're molecular gastronomist right
yeah so they're doing something there
it's just not our products one of the
things that we talk about in perception
also is Gestalt principles and anyone
who studied visual design has probably
heard of the gestalt principles yeah
yeah you know what the gestalt
principles are and we also start talking
about attention so let's just talk
briefly about the two of those so
attention has two phases there is there
is a subconscious portion of attention
where your brain is actively sorting
through all of the information coming in
trying to figure out what's important
and what isn't and if something is
important it raises it to the level of
conscious attention if something is
deemed not important is just kind of
shunted off to the side there's a ton of
sensory information around you right now
that you are not consciously thinking
about until I tell you that it is there
do you hear the ventilation system as
I'm talking
now you do do you feel your butt on the
seat under you now you do do you feel
the body heat of the person sitting next
to you now maybe you do none of those
things did you bother raising to the
level of conscious processing before
because they're really not important
right but the things that are important
you become focused on and you apply your
attention to now the problem with
attention the conscious form of
attention is that it's a limited
resource there's only so much of it that
you have and when you try to split it
across too many things you end up doing
none of them effectively and if you get
distracted it's hard for you to return
attention to something that maybe is
more important so that's why there's all
this discussion around attention
management and stealing attention and
people feeling unfocused and unable to
get their things done because we've been
designing a digital world that is
essentially created to distract you to
attract attention at marketing for years
even called it how many eyeballs can we
get on this right that's why we got ads
that move and have video off on the side
of the screen because motion is one of
those things that you are just wired to
pay attention to it might be a lion in
the brush in the Savannah I better look
right no it's just an ad for hot tubs on
the side of the news page right
it's another lion on that oh no it's
just an ad for Viagra right so we start
to get upset at the things that distract
us because we can't control these base
levels of attention if it moves it's
going to catch our attention biggest alt
principles just quick list of them over
there everybody knows these visually so
we can take a grid of objects and just
by manipulating the spacing in this grid
we can create different types of
perceptions right and even grid and
inset square three columns an orange
diamond an l-shape whatever I just
manipulate a couple characteristics and
I change what you are perceiving
I can even play with motion right so the
law of common fate says things that move
together are perceived as a group like
this
right you didn't never seen that arrow
do it again that arrow was not otherwise
perceptible or perceivable until it
began to move and then the dots that
moved together were perceived as a group
right so we can manipulate how people
see things with some of these visual
principles now we can go beyond the
visual with the gestalt principles we
can think about manipulating form and
space and time right movement and shape
color and shape and layout but we can
also think about the gestalt principles
in terms of meaning and the function
pieces of information which are similar
to one another are perceived as related
or pieces of functionality that do
similar things are perceived as related
or functionality which is grouped
together within a product is perceived
as related so we can manipulate
similarity and proximity of information
and functionality just as we can with
visual things and we do it just as part
of our everyday practice this is just a
screenshot from Amazon right but if we
take a look at the structure of the page
what we find is that there are these
very distinct zones where proximity and
similarity of content and functionality
of meaning and functionality are created
I can find products it doesn't show up
while I do that I have a section for
account functionality I have a section
for winnowing or filtering a product set
and all of the product attributes I have
a set of promoted products they'll look
like products but they're set aside
because they're treated differently paid
placement right and then within each
product detail square or unit I've got
an image and a description information
which is related about the product is in
close proximity so the very layout of
the page is using Gestalt principles
not just visually but meaningfully and
functionally and we organize our
products around those principles as well
motivation I love motivation motivation
is defined as the force that initiates
directs and sustains behavior I think
that's a great one like why do we start
doing something why do we keep doing
something and why are we doing something
toward a specific goal initiate direct
and sustained behavior there's a lot of
different theories of motivation I just
have a couple of them listed here some
of my favorites are achievement
affiliation in power and ERG theory how
many of you are familiar with Maslow's
hierarchy all right yes erase that from
your brain
so Maslow's hierarchy has what's called
face validity it sounds really great on
the surface but it actually has had very
little empirical support over the
decades since it was formulated in other
words research doesn't bear out that it
is true in fact it's overly complicated
and people don't actually behave in at
the way Maslow does ERG theory is a
modified version of that that basically
says there's only three levels there's
not five those three levels are
existence relatedness and growth at a
base level I need things to stay alive
at the moderate level the mid level I
have social drives and a need for
affiliation relationship and contact and
that growth is what we what Maslow
originally called as self-actualization
right that was the the achievement that
was I'm trying to be my best self kind
of thing so that was individual growth
so ERG has better empirical support if
you like that type of pyramid approach
so next time someone pops up one of your
product managers pops up Maslow's
hierarchy you can say yes it looks good
it has face ability it lacks empirical
support actually a better way to talk
about this would be ERG theory that's
Alderfer
is the researcher and then your team
will hate you
all right so let's use one of these
motivation theories to talk about like
the burning question of our time why do
we spend so much time using social media
and on social networks right so if we
think about what motivates us to stay
there and to spend so much time there
well we can draw off of affiliation
achievements and power as one of those
theories and we can say well we're
social creatures innately humans are
social and so social networks are
appropriately named they put us in
contact with other people and we are
driven to have contact with others so
that's table stakes right that just
makes sense but we're also very
competitive and we compete with
ourselves and we compete with others
this is Jane Wang's Pinterest page do
any of you know who Jane Wang is she's
not actually a chinstrap penguin from
Antarctica I'm Jane Wang is a real
person
she's got nearly 8 million followers and
she has pinned what tens of thousands of
things across hundreds of boards at this
point in time what motivates someone to
get up in the morning and get on
Pinterest and then stay there until they
fall asleep right well if we think about
the motivations
maybe there's a competition thing
happening maybe she wants to be the best
Pinterest star ever or the most
referenced person on Pinterest or just
the person who puts the most things on
Pinterest and she's probably competing
with herself and other top tastemakers
on the Pinterest service so there's a
competition an achievement component
here we do it for social influence and
credibility we even coined the phrase
social currency she has earned a title
of tastemaker and so people who are
looking for good product ideas or good
color combinations or a design for a
wedding cake that is going to be
absolutely current they go and they see
what people like Jane are posting that's
credibility right she is earning this
and maybe she's just doing it for the
reward
we like to be light and we like to be
acknowledged and so maybe it's just
simple reinforcement yeah Jane right and
she feels better about herself so there
are lots of different potential
motivations you can probably see your
own behavior in these motivational
theories right why do you spend so much
time on Twitter and why do I fall into
the Twitter hole so often so cognition
cognition is probably my favorite area
of psychology in this entire model it's
what I started doing as applied
cognitive science in 97 and there are
lots and lots and lots of parts of
cognition all of these things that our
brain does over here in blue those are
all cognitive tasks and we don't have
nearly enough time to get into this so
once again go read more the important
thing about cognition cognition is
essentially what you are thinking about
at any given point in time it's those
conscious thoughts and the information
that you are processing but it's biased
we are essentially error-prone
meat-based computers and we are not
algorithmically driven we are driven by
heuristics and probability and
evolutionarily speaking for our brains
good enough to survive is good enough
and being 100% accurate is not a
requirement for our brains so there are
a lot of biases and most of you have
probably heard of cognitive biases right
once again there are dozens of them if
you just go to Wikipedia and you search
for for cognitive biases there's a
fantastic page there's also a really
good diagram from a couple years ago big
wheel of cognitive biases that someone
organized all of them into categories
and it's like you have to print it like
six by six poster to six foot by six
foot or two meter by 2 meter poster in
order to actually read all the detail on
it but it's a lot of fun well if you're
into cognitive biases
alright mental models this is a concept
we all know in UX and it comes from
cognitive psychology right so mental
models are people's expectations of how
something works Dorothy and scarecrow
and lion and Tin Man they have an
expectation of how the Wizard is going
to be when they get to the Emerald City
right he's going to be this grand
beneficent Being who will just
altruistic aliy help us and send Dorothy
back to Kansas and fix all of the
problems with with the the Scarecrow and
lion and Tin Man and then they get there
and this is what they see right this
giant green yelling flaming head that
tells them go murder someone and come
back with evidence ok this is not what
they expected this is the conceptual
model this is how the Wizard was
designed to be experienced right this is
what a designer did essentially so there
was an expectation and then there was
the designed product what we find at the
end of the movie in fact is that beneath
all of that fire and brimstone is a
timid little old man behind a curtain
who is actively turning dials and
flipping switches and levers and things
like that making this conceptual model
work so how it really works under the
hood is the system model now for us as
designers most of the time we are
working on top of very complex systems
and our goal is to make them easy to
understand and simple to use
so we try to develop a conceptual model
that is aligned with people's
expectations their mental model and to
make it simple and easy and to conceal
the complexity of the system that's how
your car came to be how many of you
drive about everyone right so your car
is a very complex machine of multiple
systems but you don't think of it that
way
you get in you sit down you put on a
seat belt you turn a key or press a
button there are two pedals on
fluor there's a lever on the on the
floor between you and then there's a big
wheel and there's that optional turn
signal thing right but for the most part
that's driving I turn the wheel I press
the pedal the car turns the car goes all
of the complexity of the engine and the
mechanics is concealed from you so you
are experiencing the designed model the
conceptual model and you have
expectations about how it is going to
work and all of that is cognitive psych
emotions we try to design for positive
emotional experiences all the time
there are basically two approaches to
emotions you can categorize them or you
can have arguments about the
relationship between physiological
states cognitive thoughts and emotional
experiences that's essentially what
those theories are you can have the
categorization approach such as Ekman or
all of these others who just say yeah
there's a physiological component a
cognitive component and emotional
component and they come in different
times and proportions we're gonna focus
on the categorical one because
practically speaking that's easiest for
us to handle in design they look things
like this right emotion wheels what are
the positive emotions what are the
degrees of positive emotions what are
the nuances between emotions things like
that and it gives us a language to talk
about what people's experiences are but
we also try to design emotion into our
products and we often do so with visuals
we do things with the UI so we
manipulate the imagery like we have
clever illustrations or we have
beautiful photographs and they help
evoke things right we also have color
associations now these are culturally
bound they change around the world so
what a color means to a North American
may be different than what color means
the same color may mean to someone from
South Asia or from Africa or indigenous
peoples of South America but like for us
this is probably read as anger Green is
envy blue as sadness yellow is cowardice
right there even built into our language
into our idiom and
and metaphor
but we have to be careful because
sometimes emotionally Laden colors can
be misused these are all colors of grief
sadness loss but they vary around the
world and if we use the wrong color at
the wrong time in a UI which is meant
for everyone on earth we may
inadvertently convey something we didn't
mean to convey right now these are all
very visual things that we do for
emotions we just need to think remember
it's not just visual it is about the
entire experience we are talking about
UX design so it is broader than just the
interface we can even play with
typography right like you can imagine
reading this you will always be mine I
sound so like loving and kind and gentle
right or boris karloff says this to you
right yeah which one do you want to hear
there's not even there's not even sound
here but you perceive these as so very
different right and all we've done is
manipulate color and the form of the
exact same words and we've conveyed very
different experiences right social
social psychology once again lots and
lots of things about social psychology
we could go in great detail for some of
these so you can go read up more about
this stuff um this is this has stuck
with me for so long this was something
that one of my professors
um taught me as an undergraduate and
it's an insight about your own identity
and where it comes from I am not who you
think I am I am not who I think I am I
am who I think you think I am this is
called Cooley's Looking Glass self that
our self perception is based on what we
think other people think of us so if we
think other people think we're bad or
dumb
or incompetent or incapable or that we
don't belong then we come to believe
that about ourselves whether or not
other people actually Harbor those
beliefs
that's the quizzical part right I think
what you think is Who I am NOT I know
what you know is who I am it's all about
perception and that's a very social
psychology thing some of the theories
attribution theory is one of the key
ones for us we tend to blame when things
go wrong we tend to assign different
blame based on who they go wrong for if
something goes wrong for you it's
because you're an idiot
if something goes wrong for me it's
because something was done to me and I
was subjected to it and it wasn't my
fault it's called the fundamental
attribution error we tend to think that
things have gone wrong for other people
because of their inability but they've
gone wrong for us because of our
circumstance and it's a built-in bias
right we all do that we have to actively
remind ourselves that when something
goes wrong or a mistake where error is
made by others it's not necessarily
because they're bad maybe there is a
situational circumstance so situational
versus dispositional
all right and finally behavior this is
what we exhibit anyone who's taken an
intro psych class is familiar with
classical conditioning and operant
conditioning and social learning theory
and we probably even have talked about
reinforcement schedules and stuff like
that so there's a lot of stuff that we
do in our daily design that is actually
based on a lot of modern behaviorism we
manipulate how often reinforcers are
given we manipulate the value of those
reinforcers high value vs. low value we
create models and instructions to tell
people or show people what to do we
manipulate salience and attention look
here I'm taking your attention we even
use these design principles for
accessibility and availability so this
is also like cognition one of the most
pervasive aspects of psychology that
comes in to UX design now I want to just
give you the standard caution there is a
dark side when we are talking about
design we are often talking about
behavior manipulation we're talking
about modifying someone else's behavior
to get them to do what you want them to
do or what the product may want them to
do so sometimes in the course of our
work an apparently gentle old person may
ask us to do something that we realize
is going to potentially lead people to
do something they would otherwise not
have chosen to do right these are what
we call dark patterns in design where
you intentionally mislead people to
interact in a way which is against their
better interests so what I would say is
yield the blue lightsaber right make
sure you're the good one this is
something that Haley talked about when
she was talking about designing for
values and understanding people and as
designers we're in a position often
early in product design to identify
those times when we may be trying to
change people's behavior for our benefit
not for theirs and the question should
we be doing this should we even be doing
this
is the question that needs to be asked
all right so now we've got the whole
model of context we've got a whole bunch
of psychology we can talk about the
psychology of interaction we can even
dive in a little bit more deeply and
talk about the psychology of interaction
design and present this as a model so
we're gonna start pulling these things
together I'm gonna fly through this one
because it's fairly straightforward at
the beginning when a person approaches
your product the first thing is what
opportunities to interact do they
perceive what do they understand that
they can do to use your product once
they have that set of oh I think I can
touch this or gesture there or click
that or tap that they make predictions
what's each of these things gonna do
what are my goals what am I trying to
achieve and which of these potential
interactions is like me likely to move
me closer to my goal right so before you
ever interact you make a prediction is
it worth doing this right is this the
right thing to do and then you make a
choice and you interact with the product
then something happens right what
happens is the product provides feedback
maybe it says wait I'm gonna go look
that up for you that's feedback maybe it
says oh I need a little more information
can you tell me more that's feedback or
it says here's what you asked for link
and it shows it to you and that's
feedback so there are lots and lots of
different forms of feedback but it's the
result of your interaction it's the
outcome if you understand that feedback
then you start to learn right but you
might learn different things if you
understand it and it's what you wanted
you learn oh I should do that again
if you understand the feedback and it's
not what you wanted then you learn up
don't do that again
right so it's basic reinforcement and
Punishment ideas when we have a product
we tend to use it a few times before we
become really comfortable with it
so there's a practice period I use it
repeatedly I'd become a bit more
proficient I start to learn how to use
that product and it's important that
that product is designed with internal
consistency and that's why we have
design systems right so that when I see
something I recognize it I know how it's
going to behave I know how to interact
with it the product is consistent within
itself and if I practice enough what I
have learned gets stored in my memory
and once it's stored in my memory I can
leave your product and come back at some
point in the future and still remember
how to use it but I can also take my
prior experience and transfer it to new
similar experiences so when I come to a
new product or a new experience which is
like something I've already learned I
don't have to start learning from
scratch I bring everything I learned
previously with me and I tried that
first humans are cognitively lazy why
learn something new from scratch when
you can try to use something you already
know
right so you transfer prior knowledge to
similar new experiences now there's a
bunch of things that can go wrong in
this cycle this is the happy path right
if everything goes right people learn
your product what happens at each of
these phases if people exit the loop but
if they drop out what if I get there and
I cannot perceive any opportunity to
interact well I just ignore it right I
leave I don't even bother to try I have
no idea what to do or not worth it I
make that judgment I'm out what if I
make a prediction but I don't think that
I can do anything that is actually going
to help me achieve my goals well I know
I could do all of these things but none
of that seems appropriate for what I
need I Bandhan right I'm out I'm not
gonna try what if I interact in the
system fails
it says comes back with a 404 or it says
nothing was found or I'm sorry Dave I
can't do that right I leave right I'm
out the system broke there's an error
and I exit what if the feedback comes
back and it's obvious that this is not
what I wanted or needed and I'm not
headed in the right direction I tried I
quit I'm out
what if I get the feedback but I
misunderstand it and now I head off on a
wrong path and I'm starting to learn the
wrong thing instead of what I should be
learning what if I'm practicing and I
start to make mistakes takes longer for
me to figure things out or I keep
discovering new aspects that I didn't
see before right I may not decide to put
much more effort into this if it seems
like it's gonna be too much work what if
I have remembered something but it's
been far too long since I last used it
no if the last time you logged into the
IRS website to file your taxes was last
year you're probably going to have to
learn the website again this year you've
probably forgotten what you learned last
year what if I am not sure that this
product is similar to something I
already know I made out myself and did
not transfer any of my information or
what if I think that this product is
similar to something I already know but
it's not what if I misinterpret my
current situation well I may make a
mistake and try to use the wrong
experience and the wrong prior learning
so we have a happy path and we have a
whole bunch of potential exit points and
we can use this model at any point to
basically say where am i what am i doing
what are my options is this the right
thing what might go wrong so I'm gonna
go through these also fairly quickly
lots of words you can come back and read
perception what is it and when are we
likely to exit right we don't perceive
the opportunity to interact even if we
need or want to interact I don't know
what to do
can't figure this one out this is where
we often have discussions around things
like signals and signs and affordances
and perceived affordances this is a hole
that I argued with myself for the past
week whether or not I was going to dig
and jump into so I am going to say that
I have a personal pet peeve against the
use of the term affordances designers do
not place affordances in
anything you design signals you put a
signal in your product as it says you
can do something here an affordance is
an innate understanding of how your body
interacts with the world around you can
you throw a handful of water at me does
anyone think that you can throw a
handful of liquid water at me can you
throw a ball at me who taught you when
you were a child that you can't throw
water no one right you understand that
walking up a steep hill takes a lot of
energy you understand that you can't
throw liquids
those are affordances the signals that
we design into our products have been
called perceived affordances because we
often mimic characteristics of the
physical world to make people realize
there's an opportunity for interaction
here a shadow for depth little lines or
hash marks for texture things like that
if you're putting a button on the screen
you're putting a button on the screen
you're not putting an affordance you're
putting a signal press here the button
is a signal so that's my pet peeve right
and I know I'm gonna lose it because
everyone still says affordances all
right so prediction we make a prediction
we want to make sure that it's taking us
where we want to go we interact we're
less likely to interact remember this
formula from earlier if we think it's
going to be too much work for the value
we're going to get out of it and if
we're not very confident that it's going
to do what we need anyway why try
feedback we're less likely interact if
the feedback does not align with our
mental model with our expectations and
with our needs if I don't feel like it's
moving me forward I'm gonna abandon I'm
gonna get out of there what we learn now
one of the things about learning is we
should think about sorry is if we go
into practice when we talk about
practice one of the things to consider
is friction we use this phrase all the
time cognitive friction right so we can
think about friction propose it as a
formula what do we mean by cognitive
friction right well if the value in the
urgency
is high but the time to learn is taking
a long time and the amount of effort it
takes to learn that that's a lot of
friction right if you're making people
stop and think and work cognitively to
understand something its friction and
the more friction there is in an
experience the less likely people are to
want to practice and the less they
practice the less they learn and
remember
of course memory then and the transfer
if we don't see we we live by pattern
and analogy and if we don't see the
connections we're not going to transfer
that knowledge so and then finally
talking about consistency and I like to
use the term cohesion or cohesiveness
instead of consistency because the word
consistency makes people think about
visuals it all looks alike cohesiveness
however says this is a system of
interconnected parts and they work
together and they have resembling
characteristics if we have cohesiveness
then it's easier to perceive and it's
easier to predict and we get better
feedback and we have stronger learning
and we're more likely to remember and
transfer so design cohesion and system
cohesion is critical for this model to
work effectively all right so we have a
big model of interaction design we also
have a whole bunch of psychological
information and we can put them together
and we can say at every point in this
phase there are certain aspects of
psychology that are relevant for us to
be talking about when do we behave when
are we thinking almost always right when
do we have emotional experiences what
motivates us when do we start to do
things and how long do we do them when
is perception critical to understanding
what people are doing and when do we
need to consider social components or
social aspects of interaction so we can
take everything that we talked about
with context and experience in
psychology and put it together into this
sort of rainbow race track
right how do we apply this model let's
do this real quick
first question does anyone here work for
Tim Hortons as anyone designed the Tim
Hortons app all right so how many of you
use this app all right so we're gonna
just do a really quick dive into this
you and up try to apply this model from
the perspective of where might there be
moments of friction or confusion or
moments of success in the experience
this is not a deep critical analysis of
Tim Hortons and I am NOT here to make
any commentary on Tim Hortons I'm sure
their app works perfectly fine for what
they need I think there's a few
opportunities they could improve it and
so how did I identify that without
actually doing any research well I used
this model and fie heuristic ly about it
so first context I did this as a new
user first-time installer of the app I
have prior experience with the Starbucks
app that's the situation the app is on
an Android phone so we know context
experienced expectations I think it
should have feature parity with
Starbucks and I don't like the Starbucks
app either what are my goals well for
this particular case I just wanted to
find the Tim Hortons although I suspect
I could pay through the Tim Hortons app
or probably order things through this
importance app but I really wanted to
just find the locations so those are my
goals productivity based task focused
specific outcomes so fire up the app and
the first thing is this who are you
right so I have to create an account
somewhere so I'm just going to proceed
with Google so I start my app and I get
on an airplane and I think I'm gonna
take some screenshots of the experience
so that I can put them into this deck
and I'm ready to start perceiving right
I want to take a look at the app and
what do I think I can do
well the first thing I discover is there
is no offline mode of the Tim Hortons
app that if you are not online with an
active data connection you are not gonna
do anything so I waited until I landed
in Toronto but now it's here and the
first glance percieve ability what do I
think I can interact with I'm just
pointing at all of the things I think I
can tap or slide I'm not sure if these
little tabby things are gestural or tap
interactions maybe both I'm making a
prediction that little coffee and donut
with zero purchases in the middle
actually kind of looks like it should be
a big ol border button right like get
coffee donuts turns out that one's not
interactive I'm the biggest buttony
looking thing on the screen actually
isn't a button and then there's these
little code things right one of them
looks like QR the other one looks like a
bar chart and I'm not quite sure what
that represents but I'm predicting
they're interactive so I try to find a
location I have arrived late at night
and when I'm first looking at this
screen I don't notice a subtle
difference I see a bunch of gray pins
and a bunch of X's but one of those
little grey pins is different from the
others and I did not notice that right
away it took me a little while so when
we zoom in and we look we see X X and
this one and I didn't I'm like what's
going on X turns out that they're closed
right they're not open and the checkmark
means they're open but open and closed
or both gray and the icon is small and I
missed it but when I tap on it now it
shows me oh this is the one you selected
and it's green because it's open but I
can't actually tap on any of the others
oh I can tap on them they just don't
react it doesn't tell me closed it
doesn't read or anything it just no you
can't have this so I'd make some
predictions about my interactions what
is going to happen so now I'm on this
homepage and I tap into these different
things and I start to realize boy
there's a lot of stuff here and what do
these things do and where do they go and
I'm not sure like why if I tap on one of
these I get a QR code but if I tap on a
barcode
I don't get a barcode I get some
instructions or if I order through the
app I'm going to a completely different
experience instead of a layer here and
it's telling me I have zero rewards but
then I have a rewards card at the bottom
why aren't rewards and rewards next to
each other and why is GPA safe to phone
on the rewards page and not on the
payment page doesn't that seem like if
I'm gonna pay I should be paying from a
payments page so I'm not quite my
predictions are pretty crappy I'm not
confident in them so now I'm gonna try
to interact and I have this page that I
go to which is another big bunch of
options right and I see this and I'm
like oh Tim's card and then I started
thinking is this a demo number and it's
just what my number might look like and
I have to put in a real number or by
installing the app did it assign me a
virtual virtual Tim rewards number so
now I don't know if I have a Tim's
rewards virtually and not physically or
if that's just an example but I'd have
to interact to figure it out and then
there's that QR code again when do I use
this
be back right so there are things that
are done well like it does turn green
yes you tapped this this is an image of
the one you are looking for so you
recognize it when you're on the street
and here is the address right this is
the one you selected so this is good
feedback
it gave me exactly what I predicted it
would if I go into my settings I see
payment methods and to add a new card
okay great I can add a credit card but
why isn't GPA here it offered me to use
GPA on the other page didn't GPA be an
option here - and I have no order
history of course because it's the first
time app I have no payment history
either but it's telling me to add a card
so with no order history why doesn't
have an option to place your first order
or better yet why doesn't the marketing
department say save 20% on your first
order from this page right get people to
buy so now we have a little bit more
feedback I come to shop I find a nice
cappuccino and that image is carrying
through it's confirming a medium and in
my order I see the same image again
thumbs up for the feedback right product
product product no words are necessary
I'll recognize it the whole way through
what am I going to learn well I have to
learn certain things some of it are
explicit instructions select a
restaurant some instructions to use the
map zoom in to find your closest Tim's
they're actually giving me on-screen
instructions to help me understand what
to do but there are other things like I
have to learn the green means selected I
don't know what enable means it actually
means turn on GPS or give GPS access so
why not ask for that confirm restaurants
and view ok yeah this one and I'll take
a look at the menu little jargony but
it's fine and I'm always gonna have to
choose dine in or take out what do I
want when I go to place an order
so I learn the sequence of actions tim's
dine in go and find the menu what am I
going to practice I just have to
practice to figure this one out right
this one I do just have to do it and
make mistakes to figure it out and be
patient
internal consistency we talked about
cohesion the ex decides to change
locations there's two different arrow
forms sometimes the Menu button is there
and sometimes it isn't and in one part
of the app you get back to the home page
with a home button but nowhere else so I
have multiple ways to do the same thing
and it just causes some friction and
it's harder to learn simple consistency
we could address that what am I going to
remember well this is a case where I
want the system to remember for me if
I'm looking at a list of favorites and I
see this is one of my favorites how do I
designate this as a favorite how do I
tell it this is a favorite I have a star
but I don't have a way to actually star
a product so I think the favorites list
is Tim's favorites not mine
but I want it to remember all right so
quick review big model lots of
psychology we have an interaction design
model a happy path and lots of exit
points we can combine the interaction
model with lots of psychology and we can
get this a rainbow racetrack model of
when do we think about different things
throughout this path so now take this
and be the rainbow unicorns right and
try and put this in practice and what I
would appreciate is if you put this into
practice drop me a note and let me know
did it work you have access to this deck
tinyurl.com / designer - scientist so
all of the information is in there it's
a living deck I modify it periodically
oh I should go stand right in front of
it just to frustrate everyone but the
URL is there so thank you everyone I
know I ran long and they've been telling
you to shut up for a while so I'm around
all day if you have questions let me
know
[Applause]